laurence et harry merci de répondre ce
matin à nos questions que faut-il
retenir mais cet entretien à binh quân
le grillon sortir de cette crise prendra
du temps et requérera des actes combien
de temps quels actes je ne vous le dire
parce que
de l'entretien a parlé dans les comptes
rendus je pense que manifestement ce qui
traîne elle sait que la france a
retrouvé rapidement le contact avec les
états unis alors que comme vous l'avez
dit elle ignore soigneusement et pour
longtemps le l'australie et je pense que
un des éléments qui fait scandale à la
france veut négocier avec les états unis
pour obtenir des choses qui lui tiennent
à coeur et par mu évidemment puisqu'elle
a subi un coup dans le dos pour rené le
terme de même par lee elle est en
position de demander des concessions il
me semble que le temps long de compte
rendu de l'entretien téléphonique
entre les deux présidents français et
américain il y avait un élément qui
indique peut-être dans quelle direction
va diriger la la négociation puisque le
compte-rendu parle de la nécessité
reconnue à washington d'une d'une
défense européenne et c est encore
extrêmement vague bien entendu mais
manifestement c'est c'est une
revendication de macron depuis un
certain temps et on peut supposer que la
négociation se dirigera dans ce sens là
reste à voir jusqu'où il ira des
montants tenus
il ya une déclaration en ce matin dans
le monde je cite la fiabilité américaine
n'est plus aussi grande que par le passé
c'est florence parle et qu'il le dit
donc ce matin la ministre des armées
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
cette sortie après donc la rencontre
d'hier entre jean yves le drian et
anthony blinken
je sais pas parce que le gréement
virulent dans le secret
qu'on peut dire c'est capital a priori
on peut supposer que la france fait
monter la fait monter la pression pour
présenter les revendications
lors de la rencontre entre ba et
d'annexer france parler assure le
service après-vente c'est ça bah oui
mais ebay c'est bien normal je dire que
le au colisée en étrangères et visent
désormais se concertent c'est bien la
moindre des choses
quelles conséquences pour la diplomatie
française
dans un processus de pour obtenir des
ddpp concédé concession des concessions
américaines
sur les dossiers qui leur importe est
manifestement l'autre le dossier auquel
tient aux koulaks france c'est davantage
d'automne d'autonomie de défense ne
l'europe par rapport par rapport aux aux
états unis on peut supposer également ne
pas être plus autonomes sachant qu'à
cannes le budget
de l'armée mais budget militaire
américain c'est 730 milliards de dollars
et le budget global de l'europe c'est
250 milliards
vous mettez le doigt sur le court temps
c'est que non seulement il ya une
différence est colossale dans matière de
voyages mais également
leur matière quand on tient dans le cas
de l'europe et même les années les
intérêts stratégiques des divers états
sont extrêmement divers donc pour les
supprimer tout dans un ensemble il
faudrait un budget extrêmement important
et avant et on peut très bien j'ai eu
l'union peut très bien aller
vers la thèse ou laquelle cette idée
française de défense européenne et d'une
chimère
beaucoup d'observateurs
estiment que cette crise des sous marins
est un signal pour que la france aille
chercher d'autres partenariats vers qui
la france pourrait nouer de nouvelles
alliances stratégiques selon vous
alors
si je prends le cas de de l'asie piste
manifestement se saouler c'est là que
nous la crise quelques possibilités
l'aspect le militaire et lorsqu'à il y
aurait les indications selon lesquelles
la france
chercherait à vendre c'est souvent là
maintenant à l'inde donc là on resterait
dans une stratégie de la note de
position à la chine ou bien il ya une
autre possibilité 11 ou le car eux plus
diplomatique et dans ce cas on se dirige
vers les verts veulent les états de
l'association de l'anase l'association
des nations d'asie du sud est et
notamment de la donne et cie le
principal le pays de ce groupement qui
lui a une approche beaucoup plus
diplomatique que les relations avec la
chine
qui moins porté sur sur l'affrontement
militaire c lee les cas sont ouverts
puisque la politique française est
ambigu dans leur région d'un côté on dit
nous voulons le collaborer avec la chine
mais en même temps on participe où je
perds on se sert et loire de participer
aux opérations militaires
que pour assurer la liberté de passage
au maire d'auchy d'être 7 vera ils le le
bruit court que maps ou aimeraient à
comment dire une entente avec l'oxygène
ping mais qu'il n'a pas confiance donc
je pense que beaucoup d'options
chamassy française parce que on n'est
pas certain moi je ne
l'aurais zaïri vous êtes spécialiste des
états unis comment est ce que cette
crise est vécu du côté à des états unis
puis en scène notamment quand tony
blinken est attaché à la france où il a
vécu est ce que ça peut jouer dans la
normalisation des relations alors dans
le cas d'une option prend maintenant
l'aspect américain je pense que le
l'aspect anti français de cette crise
est due à des difficultés
de recrutement le du fait des beaucoup
de postes au département d'état qui
demande une confirmation par le sénat
n'ont pas encore été pourvus et c'est
l'école de beaucoup de directions
régionales dont dont celle de rock en
aurait donc toute cette affaire a été
prise en main par le conseil national de
sécurité ou là les nombres ne nécessite
pas de confirmation par le sénat et là
c'est bien simple quand national de
sécurité aux états unis qu est
complètement polariser sur la chine tous
les effectifs sont là je crois qu'il ya
seulement braqué changer les questions
européennes
donc là manifestement rien comme maudit
re le
déséquilibre dans les intérêts dans les
dents les intérêts américains maintenant
on voit que pas c'est assez salengro des
chaînes très nationalistes comme fox
news se moque des ambitions mondiales de
la france mini super puissance et on a
certains
médias plus comment dire plus du
classique l'anguille leur talent aux
autres qu'il y aurait fallu que la
france soit
davantage prise en considération
merci pour votre analyse laurence hézard
et je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
d'arras et spécialiste des états unis